of course reaction to the ruling has
been coming from all over the country
and of course all over nevada this is a
statement from governor steve sisolak he
tweeted in part that he is disappointed
with the ruling from the supreme court
and reiterated that he will continue to
fight for reproductive rights here in
nevada from the republican side northern
nevada congressman mark amade says in
part he will support changing nevada's
abortion protections if that happens and
reiterated that he is pro-life
gop senate candidate from the republican
side adam laxalt called today an
historic victory for the sanctity of
life now laxalt is running for
democratic senator catherine cortez
masto's seat we spoke with her this
morning
this is about women's freedoms and to
the freedom to make the choices around
their health care decisions that's what
this is about and the court today has
made it very clear they don't trust
women
senator cortez masto added many women
are already seeking reproductive care
here in nevada because of restrictive
laws elsewhere we'll have a lot more on
reaction to this landmark supreme court
decision in later newscasts here on 8
news now